oh welcome anton
thanks very much
let me make you a co-host i hope the
mathematician from the math department
will show up
and i try to send out some emails
hopefully they'll be able to come but
anyway
feel free to test screen if you want to
thanks for watching
um
yes
hmm
going on
problem here
[Music]
you're having a shoe
wait a second
foreign
okay
strange let's see
again
i just cannot connect my assets which is
horrible
there's another way you can use ipad to
finance the wi-fi again
and then you have a too long game that's
totally fine
as a separate device
it also works pretty well
and then i can make the ipad also almost
[Music]
okay
so
let's go
the other device i don't also recommend
login
that there will be much
probably you will see the screen on the
other desktop or whatever and
i i joined with another i joined in
another
account from john
use the one that you you just speak
earlier to speak but use the the one
that you just log in right now
try again
so there's no urgency
okay
so so i recommend the ipad one uh this
canelo audio and
use the desktop to share the video
muted
myself i guess
okay how about now all right
um
all right should we work now
okay can you like allow me
to share my screen
you should look at it and the rest of
the issue
just just go ahead
you will say that you need to run
no but um
your calls
see
okay
so
can you see my screen
yes
and also
i think uh i think actually
by the way five like
if you want you can also use
something i think i'm probably
suggesting this just in case i think you
can use desktop as the
laptop for the the voice
sorry i can understand what you're
saying so i have
audio proposing
uh
yes i say that uh maybe it will be ghost
mode easier or smoother later if you use
the voice you share by the
laptop or desktop
well the ipad is fairly screen
well
so i cannot share my screen with through
my desktop so what is there
yes but you can share screen to your
ipad but the share voice and audio
and also videos to the desktop and that
will work for the event
okay you just use another audio from
ipad and then connect the audio from the
laptop this connectors and connect
later let's see so you can see the you
can see uh the more mode there there's
data down and then you can see
disconnect audio whether
the end of the option choice
uh right hand top uh there's a
upper right corner more
a little bit destroyed
and and did you disconnect the audio
is
yes
i don't know why it's better but okay
because this one i think it was stable
because we use
right so the voice from the other device
will be
so let me also do a recording
okay so shall we start
welcome everyone
developer geology welcome to harvard
quantum matting maths and physics
seminar series today it's our great
honor to have a professor anton
kaperstein uh to herself to speak about
his famous work drawing work with edward
richard and also some introductory uh
pedagogical kind of
talk on his work on either from my
individuality and geometry london
duality
so that's directly welcome until
okay it's fashionable please take over
thank you
thank you so
um i i i'm gonna you're not gonna hear
anything
new in this talk so i'm just a
pedagogical review which uh
uh so and i actually haven't worked on
the subjects for a while so i could have
given the same talk in
2007 or 2008
exactly the same talk
as you also mentioned all right if uh
audience should feel free to instagram
and ask questions i hope it's okay
yeah thank you
so yes i'm not sure
uh
who is
in the audience but uh
yeah i'll assume since it's a quantum
matter
another stop seminar so
i assume there are some people
who are not uh experts here on uh super
symmetric field theories and uh
uh gauge theories so
i i'll try to target it more towards
maybe people toward from uh with some
knowledge of condensed metaphysics
and you'll see some ideas that were you
know
which were useful and kind of
metaphysics also appear in some sort of
a bit different form in this
electromagnetic duality and its relation
to geometrical language
so in particular various defects um
and tqft ideas are
play an important role
so anyway so
so again so if you
you're not going to hear anything new
here if you heard any one of the talks
by ed witton or
myself on the on the subject so
feel free to
leave if you feel bored
so i'll start with uh discussing the
background uh in the physics background
and then eventually i'm going to connect
uh
with math but i'll warn you that uh for
me the physics and the physics much
better than the mathematical aspects of
it
so you're not going to hear much about
math here
um
so and the first thing you want to um
now there's a further issue now
great
what's going on here i don't understand
so why is it
now
okay
okay finally
it's kind of weird
something doesn't work so first thing
we're going to discuss is just electric
magnetic duality
and this is a very well known subject so
just so in the classica
in classical electromagnetism there's a
well-known symmetry
which
maps
if you just have no charges
of any kind then you have a symmetry
which maps magnetic field
to minus electric field and electric
field to
magnetic fields
this symmetry of maxwell equations
in fact it's a bit more than this
so
in some sense e and b economic and
canonically conjugate variables
you can write positive brackets between
them so it's a
it's classical filthy after all and uh
some brackets also invariant under this
transformation
so
um now on the quantum level so on a
situational symmetry um it's not a
symmetry of the action by the way
because the action
so the action is
[Music]
something like this
and actually changes sign
under
if you switch if you do this
transformation
um nevertheless it is a symmetry on the
quantum level in the sense that the
path integral
is um
there's some change of variables in the
path integral which has this effect but
actually it's a bit more complicated on
the quantum level
you also have
crystal because you have an extra
parameter
and uh
in the theory called the theta angle
so theta angle
is a real parameter but it has
periodicity
so this this is um so um strictly
speaking it's true when
the manifold for manifold in which
everything is happening
the spin for manifold
uh so
i guess i have to decide whether i'm
working on euclidean signature or
minkowski signature and let me choose
the
um
uh let me choose
euclidean signature because we're gonna
once move on to topological field
theories financially discuss it
including ingredient signatures so
anyway there's an obvious sort of
obvious symmetry which shifts theta by
two pi
[Music]
and
this symmetry
arises from the fact that integral of f
which f
divided by
8 pi squared
is actually an integer
well spin condition is required because
you know in general for manifold then
this is a only
it can be a half integer but not spin
for manipulating integers so shifting
theta by two pi shifts by s by two pi i
times a times an integer and so
exponential doesn't change
now that's an obvious symmetry but also
a different symmetry which is uh so this
symmetry called t
really i guess just a similar
identification
so that identification so it tells you
the theories with the shifted theta
actually identified
and
another symmetry that you have
is actually this duality
and
it's um
best of all explained if you define a
new parameter which unifies well sort of
combines both theta and g and e squared
and if there's all certification like
this
so if theta is zero
then this is um
if it is 0
this is just inverting essentially the
coupling e to relate strong and weak
coupling
but you know this so-called strong
coupling in this quadratic theory is
actually not really that's not strong
the theory is free anyway for any value
so it's going to it's something that is
a rather trivial duality and the
duration of this duality is very similar
to a famous another famous duality
called the cramer's one-year duality
so we can regard this for a higher
dimensional version of conversation
from to demand which commerce one is for
usually stated for
two-dimensional lattice model called the
izing model and this is a
first of all
there are the fields of
scalar fields here are the gauge fields
so
to replace two dimensions with four
dimensions and replace
um
our
scalars of the izing model with the
gauge field you're going to get this
get this duality
now and um one thing you should note
that um
it's a little bit more interesting
becomes more interesting if you look at
what it actually does to observables
so the observables
here
are
well the two kinds these um
well they're local observables
but they really all um
descend from some loop observables
they're always localized loops so
observables are just some gauging
variant function of
um
the vector potential so i forgot to say
of course that
f it's better to write it in and then
using form notation so f is related to
form
um and
e and b
together
are the same as the components of this
to form f
so um
in more detail you can also write it
so f menu
so the classical action is really in
terms of e and b but really should i
think of it as function of a
observable is also functions of a and
there are two kinds and these are the
basic variables in english theory
there's a wilson line so called wilson
loop really
which attached to
a loop in our manifold manifold
and also another parameter a discrete
one
and that's just
this function
so just the holonomy of the connection
uh raised well a is really another in
one form but the connection one form
so
the basic one is just uh hologram of
this a but he also raised it to nth
power and it's still a
decent variant of course
so physically this corresponds to
asking what happens if you insert
electric charge in the theorem which
follows some word line described by
gamma
and
so that the effect of this essentially
infinitely massive electric charge can
be represented by the inserting as
another observer i'll call it
hoofthough's observable
also associated with a loop that's a bit
difficult to explain so let me just say
it's a
insertion
of a monopole
along gamma
and m here's magnetic charge of this
monopole
now at first this
what does these words mean well
usually we think about observables as
just functions of the fields
now a wilson loop observable is such an
observable so
so this is a wilson loop
but this other adhoof loop
is not like that it's rather
prescription
to perform an integral over a different
class of fields
so which kind of fields well suppose
suppose you have this piece of this loop
so here's a loop if you look in the
microscope you just see
a line says a magnetic monopole so what
does this mean organic monopole to
follow this line
well it just means that um
uh if you
take a three-dimensional slice
uh and
intersect it with this uh line and look
what happens there then in the
three-dimensional space there is a
singularity
magnetic field
so
so the integral of
p through the surface surrounding this
charge is two pi m
that's what it means
for um
for there to be monopole so it's
basically you require this gauge to be
single and prescribed away
and you don't care what else it does
now so the singularity is quantized
so there's m as quantize it's an integer
for the following reason
uh because this integral measures the
first term class
of the connection uh for which the you
know a is the gauge function class of
the bundle for which a is a connection
so fortune class is quantized so
so then this well it's a quantization of
m
since something's a classical well uh
there's a non-classical compensation but
you can explain in classical terms
simply by saying that a is a connection
on maybe it's a non-trivial bundle but
it should be a well-defined bundle
so of course you know the fact that we
do want a to be not uh but we do allow a
to be a connection on a bundle
um is itself explained usually using
quantum mechanics
that's how zero explained magnetic
monopole
but anyway so
another hand quantization of this
parameter n in here
uh is it has total different explanation
it comes from the fact that uh
it's uh well it's what's electric charge
well that's a charge uh it tells you how
the
wave function of some particle
transforms under u1 transformations
so uh it's
basically
labels well
it's a wonderful assuming that the
transformation
property is described by some
irreducible in there for one dimensional
representation so basically and labels
homomorphisms from our gauge group to u1
so but anyway so they have these two
integers and two kind of observables of
very different nature and the
interesting thing is that this s duality
actually exchanges the two kind of
observables
it exchanges a wilson loop with
uh electric charge n and that will put
that magnetic charge m
that's similar to the
kramer's financiality which exchanges
water and disorder operators
so w is an analog of the order operator
order observable and at age analog of
disorder operator
and actually the analogy is very close
uh except there the sort of integers you
have integers modular two
so in the either model
uh yes only have uh
we only have a mod two
label
okay now okay this is uh okay this is
that's more it makes it a little bit
more interesting
uh but still it's a fairly trivial
statement so non-trivial things start to
happen
if you try to think about non-billion
about daniel's theory
now uh yangril's theory
is based on some compact
semi-simple lead group
this isn't even too simple
semi-simple it doesn't bring anything
just makes it a bit more complicated but
that doesn't really bring
any new physics
so um and then um the field
so is a
is a
now uh well something which local looks
like a one form
with values in
the algebra so this is a it's the basis
in the lee algebra
but in fact it's actually a connection
so this is actually connection one form
on some bundle someone's on a g bundle
now the diagonal's action is well known
and looks very similar
to the maxwell action except that of
course f is a matrix well it's also the
algebra value then it's only non-linear
it's quadratic function of a
and trace just represents the invariant
by linear form so in variant quadratic
form on the
uh on the
the algebra
so um so the action
now unlike uh case of
yango's theory unlike his uh maxwell
here there's no duality there's no like
symmetry in this theory on the classical
level
so
however there are some hints that there
might be something
on the quantum level resembling the
electric magnetic duality
so this is a very weak hint hence but
let me state what they are
now both uh this hence the first rows in
1976 some uh in two independent papers
which actually
uh at first seem rather about their
other different subjects
so
one is by throught
and then another one by goddard
now it's olive
so
let me start with the adhoof
so and hoof noticed the following thing
you notice that um
if you consider
well first of all he observed uh that uh
in some previous work that
there is some analog of at hoofed
operator
well that time they were known in foot
operator but
there was some anago like of a truth
operator
theory but i'm not going to
talk about for the same time being but
in this 1976 paper he extended that
and did something the following
so
he observed what in modern language
[Music]
iteration um
dangle's theory
may have
on the quantum level
one form symmetries
so he didn't phrase it this way but
that's how we would say
and nowadays
uh so what did this one form symmetry
that took different kinds of quantum
symmetries which may appear
first one is magnet what's called
magnetic symmetry magnetic one from
symmetry
um well what does it mean well this that
well what does it mean by one form
symmetry when you have like ordinary
symmetry it means you can
attach
oops
somebody oops uh somebody spotted an
error
thanks for mine
physics do use watch star
and i just has an error
sorry
yeah yeah hodge star was missing
the faces are sloppy but not that slow
so uh
so this is a hard start here okay so um
thanks for spotting this so magnetic one
from symbols what's one from what
actually what's a one-form symmetry well
the usual for uh symmetry
um
is some way to attach a number to um
to echo dimension one
closed surface
which does not change if we deform this
surface
usually we just describe this
information as a time evolution so you
form a surface using time evolution then
you say well that the charge doesn't
change
now
that was uh that so the important thing
is here that
the usual charge is defined for
co-dimension one's first surface in uh
uh space-time usually we think of the
surface as a space
now one form symmetry
attaches something to the dimension two
surface that's called sigma
so in this number
[Music]
does not
change
if you vary this surf the surface
say chain without changing its homology
class
hey there's some discussion going on
still about the my my
uh
mistake
no no worry and i think everyone
understand your notation so feel free to
keep going yeah keep going
okay so coming firm so i get a number
right so here um
um
we uh
in case of a total symmetry this is
numbers really in
uh in
uh as in the
pi one
of the group
and let me um
for simplicity let me look at the case
of g g is equal to so3
the simplest non-simplification group
which is well simplest non-billions
simplified compact
uh lead group so then pi one of so3
is gmo two
and
to a surface we can attach
element
of z2
so what does it measure well
if you restrict your
a bundle on the surface you can ask well
can you lift it to
um
an su-2 bundle and sometimes maybe it's
not possible
and
it's not possible we have an abstraction
and that's what this
obstruction so this element of the two
measures if it's zero you have no
obstruction if it's there
you have an obstruction
so um it'll be a topological thing so it
doesn't vary change if you deform your
sigma slightly
um
so but then there is also an electric
one from symmetry
sometimes
and this symmetry simply
well if you think about your connection
it really well if you look at the action
depends on the curvature of the bundle
so
uh if you shift say
well if the group has a center and if
you shift connection by some flat
connection in the center that doesn't
affect anything here so
you can
shift a
replace a by a plus alpha well this is a
connection
on
z of g bundle
so zero g is always discrete so
um
um well okay so for
for simple league groups it is discrete
for u1 it would be actually the whole
group so there you would say i would say
that l should be flat but here somehow
flattening says
if you have a discrete group then
uh flatness is automatic so it's likely
flat
which is flat
because then it's also troll string you
one case
so we have this um electric one form
symmetry so so the first symmetry just
saying well you have this number
attached to your surface in second case
you need to work a bit harder so
uh first of all you notice this is
symmetry and then you can sort of use a
generalization of another theorem to
figure out what the
um well how did it actually number to
the surface but it's still true that
this is number
so
now
for which group does it exist or this
symmetry well for rather different cases
you need a non-trivial center
say
if g is
say so3 then we get nothing
is awesome
but if you take
g2 base u2
then
[Music]
center is not trivial it's simon ii
so a center appears in one situation
evolve
should the magnetic
so sometimes there is electric similar
from this magnetic symmetry and this
suggests then that maybe there could be
maybe some symmetry
which um
now what carries these symmetries
well uh
loop loop operators can be charged under
these symmetries
and you have this at rooftop loops and
uh which are charged
um
on their magnetic for unfortunately
there are wilson loops which charge on
the electric confirmed symmetry and
if there's some duality should exchanges
two loops two kind of loops and it makes
more sense uh well it will make sense if
magnetic one form symmetries would be
exchanged with the electric one from
symmetry
so maybe there is some duality which
exchanges say
jungle steer with gauge group so3 and
young mills in theory with gauge
repressor t2 simultaneously also mapping
recoupling to strong coupling
well that's a
possibility but not a very likely one in
english theory because first of all what
does strong coupling and wickupping even
mean because
in yangon's theory on the classical
level there is a gauge coupling which is
called e i guess
and there is a theta angle and the theta
angle is well defined in quantum theory
but
it's a physical parameter but the
usual coupling e is normalized
so it depends on its unphysical reaction
the physical parameter is uh
some is actually dimensional
it's a scale where you know multi-angle
series is particularly free so it's
almost non-interacting at short
distances but becomes very strongly
interacting
at long distances develops a mass gap
and so the size of this mass gap is a
parameter not the coupling
physical
so it doesn't make sense to say that e
goes to one over e or something like
that if it's not even truly a physical
parameter
so email's theory does not have um um
a duality uh duality but nevertheless um
something like well there's some
uh interesting observation that there is
this one from symmetries and then
goddard newton olive observed another
thing
they observed that if
you study
electric charges and magnetic charges
classically
then there is a symmetry
um when the classification
is naturally symmetric
and the symmetry actually does exchange
so3 and sub 2.
and more generally
so
close classification
of a
classical
spherically symmetric
configurations
um
is
[Music]
symmetric
under
exchange
of electric and magnetic
sources or configurations
simultaneously
um
[Music]
and replacement of so3
with su 2
and more generally
replacement of a group by something
called language dual group
which
would be called gl
so um
yes i have a question also i think uh
just make sure in the earlier example
the uh duality in the u1kg3 actually
they are the same phase of the quantum
matter
so they are they share the same phase
diagram they have the same
global symmetry including one point
symmetries and also central anomalies
but here for the seo two so3 example
that you may going to establish
they are not the same
quantum phase in a sense they may not
have the same
uh total anomalies right
oh wait uh
the phase well
the phase that they're in the massive
phase both right and they both have uh
um well first of all
i just want to clarify the notion of
duality is that is that somehow
different the duality concept is that
is the duality here is not the
description of the same theory but
duality between different theories yeah
that's true in general it's relate
to different theories yeah and they are
not even having the same
phase or same or even connect by a phase
diagram in the quantum phase sense they
don't they may not in a multi-cypress
world i think it's not a deformation
clause of the same kind of uh same
deformation clause or conveyor theory
yeah they're not deformational
in general
but sometimes they are like in your one
case they are right
and uh
you know they're also done a million
examples where the dual group actually
mainly are main examples where the deal
group is exactly the same as the
original one
for example uh
i don't know take uh say
well not the simplest example but say e8
each group is a self language dual right
so in that case they are the same theory
so it's very much like want kids
so so is there a way to phrase this
maybe this type of duality or juvenile
duality in terms of some deformation
class or common field theory in the
sense of
the
just the class of the theory where where
where we maybe classify them by
global symmetries and topo anomalies or
maybe some other things but
are there some way to phrase them where
where are we identifying
exactly you're looking for but i'm just
saying that sometimes uh this uh this
duality conjecture duality
because it is a
relays different theory sometimes yes
the you just map on the parameter space
of one theory
depends on yes
yes
okay but anyway but some of them are not
deformable so they are not even sharing
the same phase diagram in my opinion
anyway
thanks
okay so um
i'm trying to answer his question
in many of these cases you can
change so especially in the n equals
four case they're clearly deformed to
one another just by varying the value of
power
so you vary the value of tau and then
you go from a description one of them is
more natural to the description but the
other one is more natural
so they're clearly deformed to one
another
the non-trivial statement is that after
the deformation there's another weekly
couple descriptions so you start from
one week a couple theory and after the
deformation you end up with perhaps
another
couple theory yeah you can also phrase
it this way yeah
all i'm saying is that yeah so if you if
you define your theory by lagrangian
then you know
so3 and c2 just different theories but
if you define it yeah using just
correlators
then they're the same theory of the
difference i'm not disputing what you
said i'm trying to connect the correct
statement you said to the valid question
the juvenile race
but is there really a deformation class
in the same
class exactly in the same group it's the
same theory these are two different
presentations of the same theory
right so that's why in particular
anomalies
oh certain other moments the symmetries
must match right
okay so um
now um
let me just say that um
okay so that's great but um it's a good
evidence for duality okay actually not
so good because nobody really believed
in this duality
for the reason that you know the gauge
coupling flows so there's no nothing
which should be you know it doesn't make
much sense to say that uh
coupling goes to one or itself
um unlike the case of a billion case now
two things which
were realized uh
here afterwards is that
to make sense of this
from this duality
that is proposed to conjecturality
need to
add supersymmetry
to add an absolute symmetry
to
make the beta function vanish identical
and uh if you decided just to add the
fields in the adjoint then there is no
hn representation of the group not much
choice you so you need your force to go
to n equals force for symmetry
and uh
for anyone's force supersomatic theory
there are lots of things you can compute
exactly
and in particular there's special states
called the
dps states whose mass you know exactly
given their charges
so
so there you know in this theory so this
theory actually is quite unusual from
the point of condensed metaphysics
so let me briefly state
what it has
so it has
the same gauge field
and has also scalar fields
also in the adjacent representation so
i'll don't indicate everything is an
android here as far as the gauge group
is concerned
uh
there are these um
six of them scalars
and then there are some fermions
so the
so
that is wild formulas um
in the four copies of them so this the
so the the group actually the cinema
tier actually has a symmetry
in global symmetry
uh so of course this is poncares
symmetry but there's also
um well let me least the one that's
important here
there is spin six symmetry
uh spin 6 symmetry which acts on this uh
sixth scalar as a vector and acts on
this um
of
this says fermions as a spinner
uh so anyway so the interesting thing
about this theory is the potential for
the scalars
is proportional to a commutator
like this
so the theory classically has lots of
vacuum
so
so now this thank you well of course you
can identify it in variant
configurations of scalars but enough to
do that you still have um uh well it can
sensible in vacuum all these guys should
commute so you might as well rotate them
to the same cartons of algebra
but
even after that you still still have
six of these guys
uh and when divided by the action of the
while group
so you have um uh this large um so this
is carton symbology
it's quite unusual situation from a
point of view normal like a
non-supersomatic field theory but it's a
pretty common in super symmetric fuel
theories so then another thing which is
common is that
we have enough super symmetry then
there are no quantum effects which can
leave this degeneracy so you do have you
do have in this
quantum field theory this
large space of vacuum
and at the generic point of this space
you know your gauge group approach is
broken down to an abelian subgroup
because uh if you have some generic
configuration with flies the only thing
which is left invariant in the gauge
group is some billion sub group which
commutes all these phi's
so you're reduced to electromagnetic
electromagnetic duality
uh to
maximal theory or several copies of it
plus some scalars plus some fermions
which are all
uh obedience and they live in this
carton symbol so that's the law energy
effective theory
uh and then of course uh
such a simple theory you can check
explicitly that the duality uh acts
uh
incorrectly so there is that's the first
check you can do but more interestingly
you can also check that
um so as far as so the massless mode
gapless modes are all uh a beta duality
but more importantly uh you can make a
like stringent uh check by looking at
the masses of um
of um
bps excitations nameless uh the one the
one which minimize which are super
symmetric in a section with a given
electric and magnetic charges
so if you're dealing with su-2 this
group is um
well you have um
where is the 3 you have this
[Music]
one dimensional t is 1 dimensional but
then we still have
six dimensional space of vacuum and you
can
at any point in this boundary space you
have just your one gauge theory so there
are there are monopoles and the
electrically charged thing uh so they're
monopoles and ions and you can just ask
how the spectrum for the debate duality
and it does so that's
well not very convincing but some piece
of evidence which goes beyond this
really rudimentary evidence that
people
discussed
in the 70s
now
eventually though uh it became clear
that this duality is not just some
conjectural thing
uh it has to be true
uh for various reasons uh really mostly
to string theory
so
basically string theory in some sense
implies this non-abelian
electromagnetic duality
also known as montoyano
so there are many way well that is thus
oh there are many ways to when it's many
string clear arguments you can give in
favor of this but basically
various string theory conjectures and
the structure of string theory hangs
together only
uh if you assume uh this this duality
holds without it just you know you
cannot uh
understand well various uh you know the
theory string theory is supposed to make
sense one perturbatively and if you
assume that that implies monthly
knowledge duality
or n equals four super angles theory
so as i said there are many ways to
explain it but like one of the
uh in some sense uh simplest
explanation is that
you can um
there's an object in uh string theory
called the five brain
which is some
which is whose language theory is
described by some six dimensional
uh chiral theory six meaning like five
spatial five one time dimension
so
so this five brain
well it has five spatial dimensions and
one time
some camera exists
so then it's compactification
so that if you compact competitive
compactify
of
sort of stack of n
five brains
on t2
gives you
the n equals four super caramels in four
dimensions in the remaining four
dimensions
and then uh the parameter
uh parameters g well sorry the gauge
coupling e and theta are determined by
the geometry of the stores in which you
can pectify things
[Music]
so in some formulation just the complex
structure
of the torus and
that complex structure is described by a
parameter in the upper half plane
complex overhaul images
but only up to
you need to identify
values of this complex structure related
by
the same transformation which i wrote in
the very beginning
this one
so if if this picture makes sense at all
you must have this identification this
duality
so
um um
okay so there is a there's extremely
good reasons to believe that duality
holds
uh and um
the question is more like becomes
what are the consequences of this
a lot of you know effort early on was uh
spent on like verifying some predictions
of duality but just to check it but once
people got confused that it's true
one could like boldly
go and look at some more
uh refined and
non-trivial consequences of these jobs
now um and um
well in general it's kind of
hard to uh deduce
well check well or reduce some
statements which you can actually
make make sense of because you know if
you have
quantum field theory a tweak coupling
will you know describe it perturbatively
but the duality maps it to a quantum
field theory it's strong coupling
and about which you
know very little
so
um
so that we can not even make sense of it
you cannot even formulate the prediction
of the form which can say mathematically
say addressed
well the way out is
to
look at some subsector of this theory
this procedure was invented by ed witten
much earlier in the context of
his
work on donaldson invariants
uh but it can also be applied to uh it
can be applied to a variety of
supersomatic theories
uh so that the idea is to identify some
sector of supersymmetric field theories
which can be
interpreted in terms of
topological field theory so angle's
theoretical is not topological but
there's a sector in it which can be
turned into biological theory
[Music]
so
now actually there are many ways to do
that
um uh but anyway the point is that you
can apply this uh to both theories uh
related by this material duality
and you get some topological filters you
can probably analyze
maybe and
then whatever computation during one
field theory should be
in another filter you would you know map
to some computational other field theory
and they should give you duality it's
predicted you're going to get the same
thing
so what sort of
things you can actually do in
topological fields
well the basically the point is that the
logical tool theory sounds
it's clear what thing which things are
well defined and what sort of
mathematical structure they form
so let me just briefly
review
sort of things which can be computed
so tqft
well in general
so it's in four dimensions for different
lessons our case of interest
well it what what does it do well for
you well
the way i say it described qft
originally was some way to assign
uh we're going for dimensions
some spatial slices are complex
to close through manifold and attach to
it some vector space
hilbert space actually
and if you have some borders in between
three manifolds
then should attach well if you first
have a
disconnected sum disconnected some of
the
of these um several manifolds and what
supposedly what happens is that filter
space just get tensor
and then you have a borderism between
one manifold and another one so you get
uh supposed to get a linear map from one
such
[Music]
guy to another
say here we have say
m3 and three
q3 so it's supposed to get that supposed
to get the linear map from
h
m three
all right
let's get a bunch of
vector spaces
um
now that's the idea formulated but now
we um
by now like people realize that there's
more information than is simply these
maps in the silver spaces
uh namely can attach things also to
lower dimensional
manifolds and this one is extended tqft
so um
what else can we say let's
by the way then just as before one last
so let me say that if m3
is simply a three-dimensional sphere
then corresponding um special case but
the silver space actually has a
it can be interpreted differently it's
also a space
of the local
it's located a point
point like
observables
so in this space has some extra
structure from this
just by virtual identification
um
namely it's a commutative algebra
so um
why in algebra well uh first of all
that's another advantage of topological
twisting in in
the ordinary in qft when you have two
local observables you cannot put one top
of the other because you're going to get
some divergence
uh but you don't get the well-defined
observable but in the biological field
theory in that sector
uh of original field theory there are
divergences so you can't put the local
observables on top of each other you get
a new well-defined observable so these
guys do form an algebra
and actually for cumulative algebra
for kind of topological reasons
um and you can see from this definition
simply because
if you have a s3 and another copy of s3
there is a
natural borders and from s3 uh
disjointedness another three with the
third issue so
it's actually a community voucher but we
can sort of play this game with lower
dimensional things too let's extend
what's extended to qft about is um
and now we can look at say
some
two-dimensional thing
so and according to the rules of extent
to kft that's attached to uh
some sort of a
linear category
a linear over field so just like the
category
[Music]
so physically what is that
well the hill press was a bit easier to
understand because hilbert space
is a space of states of the theory but
he also just say this way you can put it
differently if you have a compact um
closed manifold
you can imagine sort of essentially
compactifying a field theory four
dimensions of this manifold so you
basically get quantum mechanics
we still have time left which is
non-compact so you have quantum
mechanics
and the hilbert space of this quantum
is this
guy here
if you think about this way then um
we have a two manifold close to manifold
then you can also compactify your
field theory in four dimensional on this
two manifold and end up with the
field theory in four minus two there's
two dimensions now
what does uh two-dimensional appeals
theory have well still topological tools
theory
so but what does why do you get a
category out to it
well uh you get a category because as
well appreciated by now
a topological boundary condition for
topological field theory form a category
so um
why is that let me just remind you
probably everybody knows but anyway so
if you have say two-dimensional field
theory it leaves a two-dimensional world
shift or dimensional space time if you
wish
and boundary condition is some
way to define the theory in a half space
or half plane
but there may be different ways to
um do it
and they have two such guys then you can
ask what are the ways to
glue them and these gluings
form a vector space so they
um as it turns out
uh you can use uh
argus of non rigorous or rigorously if
you have a right x semantics
so to any pair of boundary conditions or
for a given topological field theory
pair of topological boundary conditions
you can attach a vector space
and that's by definitely you have some
boundary condition b1 and b2
the space of morphisms between b1 and b2
so i got this linear category where
morphisms form
well
spatial set of morphemes has a
structural vector space
so that's the category and so basically
again to recap between it closed to
manifold
you can attach a category of the
two-dimensional kills here which then we
can pack to find the original
four-dimensional one on this
two-dimensional guide
okay so um
and in particular again special case so
[Music]
special so
so a little special case
sphere
[Music]
so in this case
this is the category
of
loop observables
usually we'll say line observables now
but with the closure
of line
observables
or so it loop defects
so these are you know the
sort of defects or observables in the
four-dimensional tqft which are
localized on a concord dimension three
so like those wilson loops
and it's roofed loose we've seen
originally except in yongnuos theory if
you don't do anything to it these are
not topological defects if you deform
them this looks then expectation does
change
but in topological field theory you can
consider topological defects
um and
it turns out that uh wilson you know
this is a natural topological version of
the wilson loop a natural topological
version of the tooth loop
so actually we do don't lose them even
after going to the politically twisted
version of the theory
so this again these defects are also
something which has been very popular in
canada's metaphysics recently uh
mainly
due to
a work of sheldon wayne and
collaborators because he emphasized that
the importance of non-invertible defects
so so these defects don't have to be
invertible they just uh well so
so invertible in what sense well this
category of line absorbable in general
this category that they described as c
uh
just doesn't have any further structure
not much further structure but in the
case when the
again the special case is interesting
because in this case you get a much more
strategic you get multiplication
in this category so you get the monoidal
category
or cancer category
i'm sorry i have a question just to
clarify you're referring to the
tqft get after combatification as a
category or just the binary conditions
they're in that theory as the category
so they're two different interpretations
mathematically extended to kft by
definition attaches a category to
closed
to manifold right
physically in an interpretation of this
category there's a cat it's a it's
objects or boundary conditions
in the effective topological fields
theory obtained the compactification
uh i see and this category line
observables in the case of s2 are are
those lines the
red and the green that you're referring
to or well no these are okay yeah
basically except uh it's a
two-dimensional picture when i say the
line the observables i again
i interpret them in four dimensional
terms again
i see so in this picture you can only
you only see two dimensions
so in this you have two dimensions only
uh shown right but there are two hidden
uh these are hidden for uh two other
dimensions right
right i see well if you interpret the
case of s2
so
this dimension i'm talking about now is
to say dimension away from the boundary
that's actually a radial direction in
four dimensions
so there's a sphere hanging two
dimensional sphere hanging at every
point in this picture
so overall we get s2 times positive
numbers so that's the basically
uh r4 with the line well
so you get them if you look at say this
slice here
it looks like it's a just a half line
but in fact it's half line times s2
so it's basically a
r3 minus a line
minus a pointer
so that's a transfers to
sort of transfer slice of your loop
right
the point here on the boundary actually
maps to the point r equals zero in the
on r3
because we have the strongest two there
too
so yeah so this category yeah so this is
this yeah so
the line observable sits here but it
also you know in some sense embedded
into
r4
so so this picture
in case of when the c this in case of
sigma is just s2 this picture
essentially gets interpreted as junction
of two lines
of two loops or two two lines or in uh
four dimensions
so nicely
yeah so imagine the formation space have
two lines
um
thank you
yeah and then you have this space of
junk uh observable so you get the yeah
so you get a category still but now it's
you have more structure because it can
collide a lot at straight lines in r4
and you're going to get then
maneuverable structure your tensor
product
uh and moreover because there's enough
space you can move them around you can
see verify that this is actually a
symmetric mono category
so
you should add here it's a symmetric
monitor category
in this particular case
and um so okay so
that seems like something we should be
able to verify i have to say young
mill's theory um with the
gauge groups aso2
su-2 and another igneous theory with
so3 is supposed to be langlen's duel
they generated this controlling of
duality
but
that predicts that this category should
actually be equivalent so what are these
categories
um
so
well then there is some further issue
the point is that um
so i suppress this point but basically
um it's an important point
to understand this
um
so i already said that in in um
in an untwisted theory in the physical
theory there are both
wilson loops and hoof loops
uh but somehow when you twist it only
one of them survives
why is that well which one first of all
that's because results that there are
sort of
uh different twists uh for the same
topological youngest theory
and by choosing
parameters of this twist you can either
kill everything except the wilson loops
or kill everything except the two blues
so in reality there is some
family
of twists
and
promises by some primary verbal t
in cp1
um
so you can and there's some special
points there's some point plus i has a
point one
uh and
if additionally choose theta angle to be
zero
then duality maps between these two guys
uh but these are different twists uh
right so reality here not not just maps
the coupling costs but also maps one
twist to another two so the different
tqfts
and one of these tqft is said here
the only wilson lines
another one here
the only truth lines
so um
the prediction is is that the category
formed by all loop observables
in the theory is uh
equivalent to the category of former old
observables in a dual theory
but the
since they kind of twisted together it's
different
so this prediction is that actually not
very easy to verify because category of
this wilson loops on the other hand you
have a category of
loops
in a dual theory
now um
the category of wilson looks like it's
not that hard to compute
um so i'm not going to stay where it is
now but it's it's a trivial sort of
computation codes
but the category by the way so wilson
loops without super symmetry are labeled
by representations of the group so you
might have guessed that the symmetric
monolithical category we're talking
about is just
category representations
[Music]
of the group g
that turns out to be not quite right
but anyway so
yeah it's not quite right but anyway
it's possible to compute it
but it hasn't been uh done for the at
full as far as i know although there are
some computations actually rather
difficult to compute the full category
okay so even the case of
s2 if you're like after the full
structure of this category it's like the
symmetrical category it's not very easy
to vary from
anyway so um
let me just move on to
um
uh so
so what can we do well um
in the paper actually with the ad we did
discuss this uh
wilson introduced loops
um
but um you know it's kind of difficult
to determine this full structure the
category we didn't even try that
rather
there's some um
we decided to take a look at the other
case when the
you have a general
um
surface it's called it's called c now
not sigma because that's what it's
called in the paper
uh and there are two different
so
so you have a identical surface in the
two tqft say i don't know let's take g
equals
su two and here gonna have g equals so3
um and then you can you do these twists
which twists well as i said because of
this picture
if you want duality to map one decrypted
to another include different twists
so um
so let me call it a twist and this is
twist b
um
and then
you get some category
depends
um
on c
and there again there are two different
types of categories like a and b
according to this two different
perspective well in general actually
there's a whole family of them you can
vary they still over the whole sphere
but let's just stick with these two two
points
uh so there all these labels there
there's a
first of all there's a choice of your
two-dimensional um
closed manifold c
then there's a choice of the group let's
take su 2.
the choice of twist
which i say a
and here you're going to have jso3
so in the claim there's some equivalence
between this
so that's what duality predicts
and then one can try to unwind what this
means and finally more precisely what
this categories are so what i mentioned
this categories for general uh um
two-dimensional oriented manifold there
are some
continuous categories of
boundary conditions in a two-dimensional
tkft this two-dimensional topological
filter leaves not on c but on the
remaining two directions
so
now luckily uh the kind of topological
fields well in there lots of
two-dimensional topological tool
theories you might think it's uh you
know from granada's matter
perspective you say wait a second there
are no topological field theories no
interesting topological tool theories in
two dimensions
but
um
this field series we're talking about
they're not unitary so if you do not
if you decide not to work with the
unitary
tqft then there are many more of them
and
in two dimensions there are quite a few
interesting non-unitary dqfts and this
um in particular this uh
tqt you get them two dimensions on one
unit
well actually even you know the tqft is
in four dimensions that you get by
twisting and millster also non-unity
so if you're compactifying them they
don't become any more united
so those are different so luckily this
particular non-unitary 2d qfts that you
get in this complication have been
studied extensively
so um
uh there uh first there uh you start
with gauge steering for dimensions but
um
the the
so this is really a sigma model
on some remaining two dimensions
with target
with a pretty complicated target
so which is called the hitch and
manifold
and so is this guy
so first of all so so what are this
hitch and what is this target and what
is this hitch in space attached to
surface
well uh there is some um
uh
well
you can think of this as a space of
solutions of some differential equations
they're non-linear so difficult to solve
but anyway so
so this is a space
of solutions
of some
non-linear
pdes
on the surface c
so uh
this so what are this pd is for well you
have again a gauge field there on c
and
this is gauge field
the same kind of gauge for the surface
su 2 gauge group is going to be as you
tube gauge gauge field
and you also have a
um
some sort of
one form
on
c
well
with events in the edge and
representation some bundles
and there are some equations on them
which are
you can
like this
and this equations have gauge and
variance so you can quotient by gauge
transformations so the result gives you
some
space
quite complicated one
so you can do it both for you can do it
for any age group
and the claim is that you get a sigma
model with this target
now um
so
so the signal elements your fields are
just scalars uh which are
just if you're basically there's a map
from your two-dimensional
um
two-dimensional
uh
space sigma which is two-dimensional but
can be non-compact
to that complicated target
plus other things which required because
we have some fermions too because this
is a together you know if you just take
a sigma model
uh typically it's
not conformal much less topological but
if you throw in some fermions gonna get
topological
that is you can you can truncate the
sigma model again just the way truncate
the gage theory to get some sort of
topological sector
so um
where is information about the twist as
i mentioned before the different twists
you should be interested in different
tqfts well information is exactly how
you do this truncation so you just start
with this hitchin
the sigma model well it's a huge
complicated field theory but we're going
to truncate it into different ways
and these are called a and b
truncations or a and b type sigma models
and these have been extended this
particular kind of sigma models have
been extensively studied
and this is a really
different signal models are very um
uh these diff a and b type models are
well understood
and dualities of this kind have been
studied before they don't go under the
name of mirror symmetry
so um it's natural guess then that
the the reason these categories
are
equivalent categories of boundary
conditions topological boundary
conditions because the transporting
signal models
are
related by this well-known developer
known as mirror symmetry
and you can interact verify it in the
same following standard of course we
don't know whether
we don't know we can't prove this
monotony knowledge duality but we can
show that if duality holds then it must
reduce precisely to a mirror symmetry
between this
sigma model with this h and target space
of type a and another sigma model of
type b
with the different hitch and model
target space
which in modular space
so um
what did we end up well we did use some
consequence
um and
now we can analyze it using our
knowledge of
um
of mirror symmetry so namely uh
we can first of all ask what is the
what does it say well the b the b model
the sigma of type b is much simpler than
single model of type a
so in that case we can completely
describe this category in the simple
terms well relatively simple
so
um this h and modulus space is a some
manifold with some riemann metric or a
very special kind on this hyperkalem
metric
in particular it has um it's also a
complex manifold and in fact you can
choose holomorphic coordinates in many
many different ways
so there's a whole
sphere two dimensional sphere worth of
sort of incredible inequivalent choices
of homomorphic coordinates in this
but the point is that
um
say for group g
has a
s2
worth
of
complex structures
uh and anyway so the beam uh it's called
b model
uh well it's a twisted version or sigma
model single model itself depends on the
um
depends on the detailed geometry of the
space but once you twist it that only
depends on the complex structure of the
space which might have less less
information like the space of all
metrics
on this on the manifold is infinite
dimensional space of conflict structure
is finite dimensional
and it's known that the kitchen motor is
a hitch and
well the twit the b model
of this hitch in space will
will depend on the complex structure
usually that fixes your complex
structure like up to a sine or something
like that but
not here here they said this whole
sphere of worth of complex structures
but luckily we can guess which one it is
without doing any computations because
most of these complex structures
actually
uh depend uh well
depend on how you choose complex
structure on c now however in our
business
c was just oriented two-dimensional
manifold didn't have any complex
structures so uh we only we need to on
the sphere they're precisely like two
points
uh two complexes don't depend on the
choice of a
complex structure on the c so these are
the one this is the b model you get here
anyway so once you understand which
complex structure you have you can
identify this category of boundary
conditions for this b model
naive question
since all this sigma model aod type uh
uh the non-monetary theory
uh
because it makes sense to even ask
whether they are capitalists or gap
theory or maybe it doesn't make sense at
all
no i don't think it makes sense to us
okay they just have uh their sort of
zero energy sector if you wish
so there's no non-zero energy
you can
the truncation kills everything
uh except those of the zero energy
sector
okay
and and let me make sure is there any
connection as far as you know to some
quantum mechanics system which is let's
say unitary
uh
unitary system suppose suppose i do some
truncation on hebrew space does he have
any realization of application to
quantum meta system just as far as you
can
so as i know i don't know any probably
so in my mind at least this a models and
b models are kind of disconnected from
uranus qfts
right okay thank you
so anyway so
so this category then
type b
turns out to be
identified with the
derived category
of coherent shifts
on
this
hitch and modulus space and some
particular complex structure
essentially uniquely defined
from this consideration just mentioned
that's good but as for this
it's not so easy to identify the a type
there
the category attached of type a right so
which we also need to compute
so
the objects of this category are known
as a brain in the strength literature
luckily oh well in general actually we
don't understand this category very well
but luckily the hitch and modular space
is a has a particularly fairly nice
structure
so you can um
argue not rigorously that uh this
category should be also
cannot can be identified with a
uh direct category of modules or
something uncommitted basically
or quantization of this h modulus space
so
uh you can
basically say that d-modules in some
sense
so in the end you get some statement uh
that there's some mirror symmetry the
witness of categories between
this derived category of coherent
shields on the hitch and moderate space
of one group with some particular
complex structure
and
the
this category of a brands which in this
particular case can be associated with
can be interpreted as a category of d
modules
on on on a different space associated
with the group language zoology
so and this uh
equivalence well you can specialize
further
you can uh
um you can you can learn something about
well it's not just the equivalent we
know something about how this
equivalence works like in particular we
can
figure out who is the dual or at least
roughly who is the dual of the simplest
object of this category here
so the simplest one is just simply the
point you can interpret the skyscraper
shift
take a point on this moderate space take
a skyscraper shift and
you can figure one can figure out
roughly what the dual is under this
mirror symmetry
so and that gives rise to um it's a gem
statement of geometric language
you can describe
some property of the dual
um
which
mathematically corresponds to that
object being a
heck eigensheet
oh and um the properties again uh it's
best thought of in categorical terms
namely um
as already mentioned
um
you have this special
case of this category when c is equal to
uh s2
so this this um
um
objects of this that category actually
gives rise give rise to
um
defect lines in two-dimensional field
theory that we're discussing
so you have some element of the boundary
of the some boundary condition for this
uh sigma model we're talking about
either of a or b type doesn't matter
so
so here's our boundary condition maybe
and then you can ask okay so well it
turns out that well
so this is our world shift
in two dimensions
i call this the dimensional part of
sigma
now it turns out that every line
observable topological and observable in
four dimensions gives rise to
a defect
of dimension one in this two dimensions
and um
has now appreciated now very well if you
have such a thing you can sort of
collide the defect with the boundary get
a new boundary condition
so in other words um
a category of boundary conditions forms
a mod well it's a module category of the
monolithical category of
defects into dimension two-dimensional
tqft
so in particular you can collide uh you
can pick any boundary and collide it
with the defect corresponding to a loop
observable one of this will not hoot
well if you're in a situation
it's going to be a truth observable
you can in sort of test your elements or
object of this category by colliding
them with a tooth line here or
with wilson loops here
and turns out the sort of eigen objects
or in some sense of this
process so if you
sometimes get item objects like if you
take say that simplest uh object less
derived category you're pointing to just
a skyscraper sheet so that turns out to
be an eigen object
for all this wilson loops
and therefore by equivalence it should
also turn out the corresponding dual
object should be an eigen object for all
uh at hoof operators in this a twisted
theory
and that's the heca eigenshift property
so
[Music]
i guess i'll stop here so i cannot
really explain how this works
yeah but
you can like the detailed lecture in
particular by
ed and myself also which are available
online
so if you don't want to read the whole
paper you can call these lectures
thank you very
much uh
any question comments from the audience
and also to antony if you still have an
additional thing you want to say please
feel free to take advantage it's not
really a problem
no i can yeah
is long enough for me i'm not going to
do this
no problem so any question
comments from the audience please
i again have a knife question is is that
uh
i mean just for the maybe maybe more
quantum matter perspective does it make
sense if if you start from any sushi
twist non-unitary theory does it make
sense to
maybe combine this with some additional
new sectors
make the whole theory unitary in some
nice way so that the whole things
together have some unitary
uh quantum maybe some quantum field
theory or quantum method description
this this is basically one thing
i want to ask not sure what is clear
can what can one a something and make
the two the two combine system is
unitary in some way
no
maybe i i don't think that's possible
because i forgot yeah so
it's not just
what is it
additional equation for which you forgot
to write down
uh
yeah so no i don't know any like
relation unfortunately so
if you want to deduce some consequence
for condensed matter maybe you should
just go back to the original untwisted
that's a perfectly good physical you
know unity kill theory
so
um
so yeah you shouldn't twist it if you
want to connect
i'm not sure what will you do with it
though
if
if there are no
questions that are directly related
maybe i could ask
more philosophical questions but i would
first like to wait
make sure that there are no more
sensible questions
i think nothing should go ahead first
you might inspire other people to ask so
why does it work namely
how come that
mathematician studied one thing in
physicists studied something else and it
turned out to be the same
there are many things that can be
studied
on
which sides the probability that the
coincide is quite small
um
yeah i mean
i don't have any issue with the physics
side it's quite well motivated my
problem with mathematics i don't
understand
i don't understand how mathematicians
think i guess
so on the physical side the fact that
you have this duality is a has a nice
explanation in terms of string theory
it's not like a freak
thing the fact that non-priority string
apparently exists implies that this this
thing makes sense right
so the question is really how how did
mathematicians without the benefit of
knowing about string theory managed to
discover some bit of that picture right
no i don't know well they've done and
they did it earlier so it's not just
that they did it without it also did it
earlier yeah i did it much earlier and
uh
yeah so
well if i understood the
uh well first of all i think the most
mostly interested in you know what they
did was the
non-geometric language like a number
theory
i wish i don't know anything about that
so i don't understand how that is
modulated
uh
the the yeah so the geometric language
is some offshoot
uh which are roles from like
failed attempts to
prove the original language during the
conjecture
uh so
it looks i don't know to me it looks
some sort of freak accident still
that mathematicians managed to discover
it could reinforce the possibility of
the theory perhaps if mathematicians
discovered it by accident or maybe
they're regurgitating some natural law
that already exists through the
mathematical investigation
like a natural coincidence that that
reinforces the possibility that the
theory is true
well i don't know we have enough uh true
in what sense like basically so first
so we have a lots of evidence we don't
need this so
the early the characters where it has to
conclude that uh string theory is uh
well defined on perturbativeness
like that would be a really freak
accident if everything you know about uh
string theory was right but it still
would be not perfectly incomplete so
that seems to be like
ridiculous pretty absurd so
string theory is uh
at least some versions not particularly
consistent and that's a massive evidence
for that so i don't need the
mathematical evidence
uh from you know
geometric language to like
boost my confidence in that
uh
so i'm not very sure yeah so for me it's
just it's a freaky thing i don't
understand this
but it's because i don't understand
geometric duality
i don't know anything about numbers here
so
what can i say maybe it's all very
natural there
but there's a maybe a point of view
sorry for uh since maybe i'm not
qualified but i think the thing is that
because here it's about discovery
it's not invention so you discover
something people can discover from
different angles
yeah it's a discovery
so that doesn't already exist we just
discover it
so you won't be surprising different
people discover the same continents
yeah i am surprised that people i agree
that this discovery but why did
two different completely different lines
of investigation end up with the same
discovery
that's
well you could
like you could ask this question about
some simpler cases
which understand better like say
john's polynomial and uh turn simon's
theory
so those occurred pretty much
simultaneously but the line of thought
was little totally independent
well there i think it's closer than here
well the connection is just easier to
understand that's all
but no but also the the manipulations
that lead to that all these relations
that you kind of
forget what it's called when you cross
the lines and
and so forth that's essentially you
compute it essentially in the end the
same way
yeah
with churn simon's theory
here it's a little bit more mysterious
okay i say differently in the case of
the trans simon's theory the theory
manifestly exists you you analyze it
with coupling there are no surprises
here you need to use the surprises or
strong coupling
to
to get your results
yeah well i i guess
i guess
we can argue which one is more
surprising that's that's not the
question but why does it work at all
does this give us any confidence that
similar things are going to work in the
future i guess if one was like
optimistic one would say that well
the fact that some number 30
considerations lead to the same
kind of prediction as string theory
then maybe there is more overlap between
these two subjects than we currently see
so
so when i ask my questions that's what i
hoped you would say
yeah but we we just mystified because we
don't see the large overlap in this venn
diagram but uh
maybe there's
if there's two subjects or have a huge
overlap than that's surprising about it
it seems more like a 2 or more different
civilization discover the same continent
thing
i mean currently is that you said that
they have this tiny overlap right
in this very third corner these two two
two totally different areas just touch
right in a highly non-trivial way
so well
what is explanation i guess natural
explanation that there is actually
a big overlap so
i don't think anybody seriously work on
that by the way
i guess natural thing would try to fit
other number 30 conjecture the results
which is some string three framework but
i don't know
any number two so i'm not the person to
do that
uh other audience please also feel free
to ask questions
now i think we should thank anton first
thank you thank you anton thanks very
much
nice
thank you
thank you thanks
pleasure special thanks